hey 42 here tucked away in a Cupboard
somewhere in the medical Department of
the University of Sao Paulo is a 40 year
old human skeleton
to the train die the bones offer a
window into the former owner's life a
hip fracture points to an old motorbike
accident and a tiny hole in the left
cheekbone hints at severe sinusitis that
aside it's pretty much a standard issue
human skeleton one that's helped
hundreds of Brazilian forensic science
students to better understand how to
identify human remains
but this apparently unassuming human
skeleton hides one hell of a secret
because in life it belonged to one of
the most evil human beings ever to walk
the earth now I admit there's a fair
amount of hyperbole going around on
YouTube these days so I'd forgive you
for thinking I'm exaggerating here for a
fact but trust me this isn't clickbait
you see the classroom skeleton at Sao
Paulo University
once belonged to a Nazi war criminal who
was personally responsible for the
deaths of an estimated 400 000 people
that on its own is mind-bogglingly evil
but it gets even worse because this man
also used his position as a doctor
working at the notorious Auschwitz
concentration camp to undertake some of
the most brutal depraved experiments
ever carried out in the name of science
experiments that use live humans as
their subjects this Nazi mass murderer
was called Joseph Mengele but the
inmates at Auschwitz had another more
fitting name for him the angel of death
this is his story
[Music]
now I'll admit I love a bit of pampering
as much as the next month but I don't
typically do much in the way of wellness
and Beauty regimens but that's all
changed since I discovered for real
foreign Sweden is shaking up the
wellness world it's a Visionary brand in
the space where the beauty and Tech
worlds meet such as the lunar device
that deep cleans your pores reducing
breakouts to develop this product alone
it took for Rayo 10 years drawing on
talents from a multi-disciplinary team
of dermatologists cellular biologists
dietitians and estheticians the ice
arrange is the world's first silicon
sonic toothbrush it's bacteria resistant
tough on plaque and gentle on gums but
my personal favorite is fereo's UFO
range it's a professional facial
treatment device at home which thanks to
its t-sonic pulsation pushes mask
ingredients deep into the skin it's
amazingly clever stuff
so to get a spa quality facial treatment
at home use ufo2 by ferreo Sweden an
amazing supercharged facial device click
the link in the description and use a
coupon code 4020 to get 20 off
thanks to ferreo for sponsoring this
video
delving into the early years of
history's most Twisted individuals often
turns up Tales of hardship or abuse but
that wasn't the case for young Joseph
Mengele he was born in the picturesque
Bavarian town of goonsburg on the 16th
of March 1911 and his father was the
founder and owner of a successful
farming equipment manufacturer as alad
Yosef was one of those absolute bastards
who seemed to be good at everything he
was a strong student and a capable
Sportsman with an interest in the Arts
and combined with his good looks and
natural charm he enjoyed no shortage of
interest from the opposite sex he
excelled in further education too
studying philosophy in Munich medicine
in Frankfurt and eventually earning
himself a PhD in anthropology in 1937 he
got a job at The Institute for
hereditary biology and racial hygiene in
Frankfurt
there he worked under Ottmar freiher Von
visier a Dutch nobleman and scientist
with an interest in Eugenics and a
belief in forcibly sterilizing people
with undesirable genetic traits in other
words he was an [ __ ] and Mengele
quickly bought into his assholy ideas
particularly the ones about a racial
hierarchy that put people like him on
top and everyone else on the bottom
a man with mengeles scientific interest
was a natural fit for the racist
ideology of the Nazi party and he became
a member in 1937 signing up to Hitler's
personal paramilitary the SS the
following year those were happy times
for mengler he married his first wife
Irene in July 1939 when the second world
war kicked off two months later mengel
had volunteered for medical service with
the Waffen SS and by all accounts he was
an excellent Soldier serving primarily
in France and Russia and winning several
medals in the process including an iron
cross first class for rescuing two men
from a burning tank his time on the
front lines came to an end in 1942 when
he was wounded in battle but a man with
a mind like mengeles still had its uses
and in early 1943 he was transferred to
Auschwitz he was given the role of Camp
physician though that title was so
inappropriate it's almost laughable Nazi
doctors like mengler never treated the
inmates who were simply dispatched to
the gas Chambers when they fell
seriously ill no mangler's duties at
Auschwitz had nothing to do with patient
care in fact they'd have given
Hippocrates of cars and aneurysm
as well as being a place to commit mass
murder on a scale never before seen in
history concentration camps like
Auschwitz were also used for forced
labor and so the first thing to do when
a new trainload of inmates arrived was
determined here amongst them was fit
enough to work this process was known as
selection and it was the job of Nazi
doctors to make that call
it's estimated that at least 75 percent
of all the people who arrived at
Auschwitz including almost all children
pregnant women and the elderly were
immediately deemed unfit for work and
sent straight to the gas Chambers to put
that into context it's fought that close
to a million people were murdered as
soon as they arrived at the camp under
mengele's direct orders four hundred
thousand Souls including tens of
thousands of children were sent to the
gas Chambers there are reports that some
SS doctors found this task somewhat
unpleasant I mean you'd bloody hope so
but not mengler he relished it in fact
he enjoyed his work so much that he was
regularly seen smiling and whistling on
the job and he'd even turn up to help
out when he wasn't officially on shift
but it turned out there was an ulterior
motive for all that over time you see
Mengele had realized Auschwitz was the
perfect place to continue his research
into the empirical superiority of the
Aryan race in the eyes of the Nazis
inmates at the camp weren't truly human
and that opened up certain opportunities
using a grant secured by his old Mentor
[ __ ] freihe Von vescher mengler
built a lab at Auschwitz that would use
the Camp's inmates as his test subjects
that's why he was so Keen to take part
in selections they gave him an excuse to
scan the crowds for anyone with obvious
genetic abnormalities that he could
study club feet cleft palates people of
dwarfism or hunchbacks Mengele collected
them all for his own private menagerie
of genetic Oddities
but there was something he prized even
more highly than quirky jeans
identical twins
so-called twin studies remain an
important tool in science even today
because identical twins have identical
DNA well almost identical but that's a
topic for another video so some
scientists believe this clone-like
property makes twins invaluable for
studying the age-old question of nature
versus nurture
mangala felt the same way too and he
planned to use his lab to prove that
genes namely iron ones were the deciding
factor in the development of desirable
traits or phenotypes he also hoped to
find a way to help German mothers give
birth to strong iron twins of their very
own to more quickly repopulate the world
according to Hitler's mad ideal
just think of the scariest most
disturbing scenes from The Most Extreme
horror films you've seen and they won't
even come close to the living nightmare
that was mengele's lab we'll likely
never know the full extent of what went
on in those blood-soaked corridors
because the Mad Doctor himself destroyed
most of the records when it became clear
Germany would lose to war but what we do
know is almost beyond belief
some of mengeles twins had their eyes
injected with chemicals in an attempt to
turn them iron blue
whilst others were made to endure
extensive surgeries without anesthesia
including amputations organ removals and
castration in some cases one twin was
deliberately infected with a disease
like typhus or tuberculosis
when it killed them the surviving twin
will be murdered too so that's a
comparative autopsy could be carried out
to study the effects of the disease
Mengele claims to be a man of science
looking for answers to important
questions
but that was just a mask sometimes that
facade slipped entirely revealing the
monster beneath one Auschwitz inmate saw
mengler throw a newborn baby off a camp
roof and another saw him kill 14
children in a single night by injecting
chloroform directly into their hearts
one after the other
Survivor described how mengler once
sewed two children together in an
attempt to create artificially conjoined
twins they died of gangrene two days
later
this wasn't science it was murder of the
most sadistic variety imaginable of the
1500 sets of twins taken into mengler's
lab just 200 individuals are fought to
have come out alive those that died were
dissected with various parts of their
Anatomy removed for further study of
particular interest with the eyes and
one entire wall of the lab was full of
them each pinned in place like a
butterfly in a display case
several survivors report that outside of
his lab Mengele often showed kindness to
his subjects insisting that they call
him uncle and handing out candy and milk
to the younger children
sweets in the morning scalpels in the
evening
what kind of monster is capable of
something like that this utter depravity
continued unchecked for two years until
the angel of death was forced to leave
Auschwitz just before its Liberation by
the Soviets in January 1945 he fled to
Czechoslovakia where he was eventually
captured by The Americans I wish I could
tell you that at this point in the story
Joseph Mengele finally got what he
deserved that he was put on trial in
Nuremberg and left a rut in the deepest
darkest dungeon for the rest of his days
sadly that isn't quite how this story
goes in fact it's the exact opposite of
how this story goes but I'm getting
ahead of myself
just one month after he was taken into
custody Mengele one of the most Wanted
individuals on planet Earth was released
as a free man
as for why
he simply hadn't been correctly
identified there were so many Nazi war
criminals knocking around at the time
that the Allies were having trouble
keeping up with them all and despite
initially being registered under his
real name somehow Mengele slipped
through the cracks he wasted no time
going to ground working as a farmhand in
deepest Bavaria for four years before
eventually escaping Germany altogether
along one of the so-called rat lines
that provided Escape Route for Nazi war
criminals mostly to South America
Mengele was able to convince the Red
Cross to issue him a passport under the
name Helmut Greger and he used it to
make his way to the Argentine Capital
Buenos Aires to begin with he was
sheltered by Nazi sympathizers but
eventually he bought himself a Swanky
apartment in the city center to OK you
with an idea of just how unconcerned he
was about the possibility of his past
catching up with him Mengele applied for
Argentine citizenship under his real
name and he soon got a job working as a
regional sales representative for and
I'm not making this up Carl Mengele and
Sons his father's own company
by the late 50s he'd apparently decided
the folks back in Europe must have put
that whole Holocaust business behind
them because he flew back to Germany to
visit family and catch up with some old
bodies on a skiing holiday in
Switzerland a quick reminder here that
we're talking about a man who is
personally responsible for 400 000
murders and he was just going about his
business as though the second world war
had never happened if you're wondering
how the hell that was possible how this
despicable human being somehow got away
scot-free the answer is actually quite
simple the rest of the world thought he
was dead mengler hadn't been seen since
he slipped through the Americans fingers
in 1945 and his own family had gone on
record to confirm he'd been killed if he
hadn't been so monumentally stupid as to
use his real name in his new life in
South America there's a good chance The
Wider world will never have realized he
survived the war thankfully he was that
stupid and that was all it took for
famous Nazi Hunter Seaman wiesenthal to
get on his Trail in the aftermath of the
war mengele's wife Irene hadn't fancied
relocating to South America with her
Mass murdering husband and in 1954 the
two were officially divorced not that
mangle of minded he took the opportunity
to marry his dead brother's widow he
really was a classy guy wasn't he
but of course marriages and divorces
leave a pretty bloody obvious paper
trail and not only did these documents
confirm Mengele was still alive they
also listed his home address as buena's
ex having realized Mengele was still at
large Seaman wiesenfall convinced the
West German government to issue a
warrant for his arrest unfortunately
when police arrived at mengler's
apartment in June 1959 the angel of
death had already taken flight as it
happens mengler had no idea the
authorities were on to him he'd gone to
ground for entirely different reasons
along with working for the family firm
Mengele had been doing a bit of illegal
doctoring on the side Backstreet
abortions and stuff like that when one
of those procedures went wrong and the
young girl died the local press started
sniffing around they say no publicity is
bad publicity but I'm pretty sure that
doesn't apply when you're a mass
murdering face worried that the
attention might lead to some very
uncomfortable questions mengler swapped
Buenos Aires for a remote Farm in
southern Paraguay where he gained
citizenship in 1959 under the incredibly
clever Alias Jose mengler the despite
this frankly embarrassing attempt at
covering his tracks mengel approved
surprisingly hard to pin down in
Paraguay and neither siemen visenfall
nor Mossad the Israeli Secret Service
were able to bring him to Justice
thankfully their combined efforts hadn't
gone unnoticed by mengler himself he now
knew he was a wanted man and that
knowledge changed his life
he was forced to relocate once more this
time to Brazil and the Specter of
capture hung over him constantly an
incessant worry that frayed his nerves
and eventually impacted his health by
the early 1970s he developed a nervous
habit of chewing the tips of his
mustache he'd grown to alter his
appearance a compulsion that got so bad
a giant ball of beard hair formed in his
intestines almost killing him almost
murdering himself with his own mustache
seemed to have shaken a Mangler up a bit
because he briefly considered heading
back to Germany to seek medical help the
trouble was he couldn't afford it by
this time there was now multiple
bounties on mengele's head which made
guessing work risky and his support
network of Nazi sympathizers had begun
to dwindle in fact several of those who
still knew his real identity had started
to blackmail him threatening to reveal
his secret if he didn't pay up Mengele
kept a diary in the later years of his
life and the entries were in reveal a
man who was depressed poor paranoid
pessimistic and constantly poorly it's
far from the Justice he deserved but
it's something sadly the diary also
revealed that mengler never felt
remotely remorseful for the Unspeakable
things he did nor did his belief in the
Nazi ideology ever waver even until the
end
speaking of ends mengeles came in 1979
when he suffered a stroke while swimming
in the sea not far from Sao Paulo he
survived a stroke but not the subsequent
influx of several liters of seawater
into his lungs he drowned on the 7th of
February almost 35 years after leaving
Auschwitz and was buried under a false
name it wasn't until 1985 that the rest
of the world learned of his fate West
Germany Israel and the USA had finally
begun to make a combined effort to find
him and the operation eventually LED
them to a cemetery on the outskirts of
Sao Paulo and a simple grave marked with
the name Wolfgang Gerhard the bones were
exhumed and the forensic analysis
concluded that they likely belonged to
Joseph Mengele but doubts remained at
the time the bounty on mengler's head
started 3.4 million US Dollars and some
people believe the body in the grave was
a red herring planted there by his
family to throw investigators off the
scent
that theory was put to bed in 1992 when
DNA testing confirmed the bones belonged
to mengler for obvious reasons the
family weren't Keen to have his remains
returned to Germany which is how they
ended up locked away in a box and Sao
Paulo's Institute for forensic medicine
they remain there for some 25 years
before a faculty member realized he
could put them to use as a teaching Aid
we're used to the idea that true
unfiltered evil is something that can't
be concealed whether it's a terrifying
clown makeup of John Wayne Gacy or the
cold dead eyes of Ed Gein we assume that
a rotten inside will eventually be
visible on the outside too
but that wasn't the case for Joseph
Mengele this could be a picture of your
mate's favorite grandfather well minus
the SS Insignia he was handsome he was
Charming he smiled openly and often and
yet this man wasn't merely a wolf in
sheep's clothing he was a monster draped
in the skin of a man during the second
world war he committed some of the most
unfathomably evil acts of any human
being that's ever lived and he did it
all with a smile and a sweetie for my
money the fact that he was never made to
pay for those crimes remains one of the
biggest travesties of our time
thanks for watching